disappointed disappointed the results that was
waited it's very scary to chopin little
irremediable weather pretty hot how
the idiot the national movement is
now without question the first party
of France
but he's also the only one for sure
who can reconquer the territories
lost from the republic of calais where
tonight we are putting 50% of the votes or
our suburbs
the fn is a party that tries
to optimize who will insult the
Muslims the gays external all
the minorities he uses disarray
and the discontent of people but he
proposes no viable solution and the
program was not quite at the
reality it's just that they handle
people and if all
people are not aware of what
wait for them but the election
presidential election best in 2017
we can actually see a threat
hover over the country if the pen wins
election